ciao ragazzi bentornati a un nuovo
guglielmo tell mi trovo in questo
momento all'interno di uno con quindi
oltre a sentire la mia voce del
legamento versi sentire anche le cicale
che stanno fattori infatti sto
utilizzando anche il telefono per
poterla registrare qualora la
videocamera che è stata posta a sette
chilometri da me con un piccolo
microfono sopra non riesco a prendere
bene il suono comunque su instagram ogni
tanto vi chiedo di farmi sapere che cosa
fare quando mi annoio mi trova a vivere
un parco e quindi l'ho chiesto di farmi
sapere esattamente cosa fare all'interno
di un parco detto ciò dire a questo
punto di partire subito imita i tuoi
fratelli cugini ciao sono gabriele
esposizione mediatica l'uscita di
sicurezza sono qui qui qui qui qui qui
qui lo sguardo poi devo aggiungere tipo
un aneddoto su di merce legge così
il rigore non la mangio quella cosa non
mi siedo in una panchina non esiste un
altro marco ragazzi io non sono proprio
un fan di questo parco e poi alla fine
tipo ciao ragazzi sono al parco
guardate il mio bellissimo sorriso
ieri ho incontrato questo ragazzo due
metri e mezzo per 200 kg questo qui è
venuto con tre macchine ci aveva un
piede in una un piede nell'altra e
l'altra la teneva sulle braccia quattro
incontri ed è cucciolo di biancaneve
tassi un monopattino la vita era più
facile risaltato recita musica il resto
scompare come fosse una tragedia greca
mi piace la musica fino al mattino
faccio casino lo stesso ma non bevo vino
riti cretino
la vita è corta per l'aperitivo
innamorata di un altro cabron est e sla
si storia è una morra evoca il tuo
patronus expect o patron ha premesso una
cazzata e stupida premi un bastone gira
dieci volte con la testa attaccata a
questo e poi inizia a correre e veloce
al di là chiesto come preoccupate le
corre fatti un orecchino con la prima
cosa che trovi alla tua destra
questo mi sfondo mi arriveranno i gobbi
a terra
facciamo una cosa più sala piena mia
destra giammarco non mi posso fare un
orecchino che giammarco dove non puoi
disposizione mediatica a chi o cosa
attira la tua attenzione nel parco
quelle anatre aspetta del cibo ma non ce
l'ho non ce l'ho guardato ditte carine
suona un filo d'erba salutame mia
sorella in 10 lingue diverse riccardo
eleonora ciao riccardo eleonora riccardo
hunt eleonora ora riccardo eleonora allo
riccardo un telo nota che cosa che cos'è
il divieto riccardo eleonora cecere
riccardo eleonora penso riccardo che
eleonora konichiwa riccardo e dopo
eleonora mia o di caldo e molto
difficile il cinese ragazzi ma capanne
riccardo a eleonora ma sa benissimo
l'arabo fatemi sapere se ho fatto schifo
mettiti un piede dietro la testa noti 0
forse la destra pareri che ci fa vedere
con un perduto
comprare qualcosa di stupido su internet
da usare in vacanza coi tuoi fratelli
cugini
vado subito cosa ordinare una coda alla
sirena io voglio poterci nuotare
veramente c'è xl ma solo malibu rosa
grazie alla solo bisogno di una scusa
per comprare la vita dalla sirena non e
cognome guglielmo anzi no alla vigna
scannerini non ce lo metto il mio nome
acquista ora sono sereno stranieri su
prato sotto un albero fai un bel respiro
e di la prima cosa a cui pensi
[Applauso]
quest'estate sarà una sirena a me
sicuramente pigro non molto intelligente
che fare con gente è mentalmente più
avanti spagnolo parla male di una
versione che krupa riprendendo senza
farti capire che se lo abbiamo chiesto
ti prego il link per la crema di ricci
guarda che pazzesca asta crema per i
ricci ragazzi pazzesca vi lascio qui
sotto il link è pazzesca carla la non mi
pagano poi ma è pazzesca bagnati o
asciutti ha fatta non sembra
assolutamente sembri pegli pubblici
quando tu fai queste cose fai più ruote
che poi tutti e di seguito si supera 2 0
se non viene fatto alla terza cade
ai abbiamo affrontato ciò che ne ha
fatti tre
tutta la vacanza rovinano sono stato
l'ultimo serve la gamba di essere uno
studente arrampicati sul primo albero
alla tua destra
adesso quel muscolo e guarda il bozzolo
di un mostro è diventato una bellissima
[Musica]
voglio si muove dicano no vabbè scala
fan the roadie un medico saltare ma no
sì lo voglio fare in dinamiche mondi
corsa sono salito e dinamismo ottenuto
la fine di una favola fai finta di
essere bear grylls venite venite ci
troviamo davanti a una delle specie più
pericolose al momento all'interno di
questo parco è in un posto così lontano
dalla civiltà
guardate è una terribile terribile
terribile e pericolosa la tartaruga si
sta avvicinando all'altra tartaruga e
stanno per scannarsi l'anima è una delle
due e finirà per mangiare e nutrirsi e
l'altra una tartaruga si sta avvicinando
fondato carabina scherzando non ci sono
tartarugato guarda un uccello la cosa
migliore da fare con questi uccelli che
sono pieni di nutrienti specialmente
quando è molta fame se il lontano dalla
città e di afferrarli per il collo e
cerca di mangiarli quando ancora
chiamano la mamma l'unico modo che
esiste per avvicinarsi a questi essere
quello di provare una danza
dell'accoppiamento che proverò adesso
guardate vieni qui le anatre possono
essere molto pericolose specialmente
nella stagione dei veleni che una
piccola parte dell'anno nel quale
effettivamente sono velenose vi dico
solamente che il morso di una di queste
stronze potrebbe uccidere una mucca in
due minuti ma quando emergono la testa
sott'acqua in questo modo quello che
stanno facendo e che si stanno dando del
piacere ma soffiandosi da sole cammino
ormai la mezza giornata e sto morendo di
fame
ho bisogno di acqua cibo ho trovato
queste piccole
la cosa migliore al momento è quella di
mangiarle come snack se tu alla fine
chiudi gli occhi bassi la lingua ed i
massaggi l'anno ci senti proprio il
cioccolato ecco vi faccio vedere come la
mangio e vi faccio venire la diarrea
ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di
questo video spero vi abbia divertito
fatemi sapere come state passate le
vostre vacanze essere state passando
spero che questo vengono scoperti da un
modo rovinando anche la ripresa audio
che sto facendo mi mando un bacio
grandissimo come sempre al prossimo
video ciao